[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 11 mai voici le programme de ce
soir chaque année Pôle Emploi mène une
enquête sur les besoins en main d'oeuvre
au niveau régional et départementale
dans les Yvelines 28% des établissements
envisagent de recruter cette année quels
sont les secteurs en tension quels sont
les métiers recherchés ont fait le point
avec Philippe kamples directeur
territorial pour Pôle Emploi Yvelines
après le Vélodrome et le golf national
en 2022 cette fois-ci la tournée décide
olympiques s'arrête au Stadium de BMX de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'initiative
du club Paris 2024 cette tournée permet
à quelques participants de découvrir les
différents sites olympiques en
avant-première et de s'immerger dans la
peau d'un champion
découvrons sur place notre journaliste
Grégory canalet et puis comme d'habitude
le jeudi à l'approche du week-end nous
vous donnerons nos idées de sortie dans
les Yvelines au programme une exposition
de dinosaures un spectacle comique ou
encore notre sélection pour la Nuit
européenne des musées les détails en fin
d'émission avec notre journaliste
Gabriel Gontier et en plateau avec moi
Philippe Kamp bonsoir alors je le disais
à l'instant vous êtes le directeur
territorial pour Pôle Emploi Yvelines
comme chaque année Pôle Emploi sort son
enquête annuelle sur les besoins en main
d'oeuvre quels sont les secteurs qui
recrutent le plus cette année
nous parlerons également de mode
éco-responsable avec vous Alison Laurent
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
créatrice de mode pour Kentucky reign je
sais pas si je le prononce bien
et vous êtes à l'origine d'un défilé de
mode éco-responsable qui aura lieu à
l'Hôtel de Ville de Versailles ce sera
ce dimanche pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé de de lancer ce défilé
éco-responsable on entend beaucoup
parler des effets néfastes l'industrie
de la mode surtout de la fast fashion là
actuellement et donc on essaie de faire
découvrir une alternative la mode
éco-responsable pour ceux qui sont
encore un peu sceptiques ou pensent que
c'est trop difficile de changer leur
mode de consommation donc on en parlera
également plus en détail tout à l'heure
avec nous également une journaliste de
la rédaction de TV 78 régénéralège
bonsoir bonsoir avec vous on en saura un
peu plus sur les informations à retenir
dans les Yvelines aujourd'hui dans cette
émission également direction le
vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et plus
précisément au stade de BMX qui est
situé juste à côté Grégory canalet vous
êtes sur place car la tournée des sites
Olymp de Paris 2024 fait étape ce soir
sur le site yvelinois
oui Mathilde s'est à proximité directe
d'ailleurs de cette piste de BMX au
Vélodrome national qui avait été lancé
cette tournée des sites olympiques
c'était en avril 2022 Tony et sanguin le
président du comité d'organisation de
Paris 2024 était venu spécialement pour
l'occasion sur place elle a tourné été
ensuite passé en juillet cette fois-ci
du côté du Golfe national un autre est
des sites de paris 2024 alors le
principe de ces tournées et des sites
olympiques et tout simple au-delà d'être
un événement dédié à la presse c'est
aussi l'occasion de donner à 24
personnes tirées au sort et membre du
Club de Paris 2024 est de venir
découvrir les différents lieux
d'épreuves de Paris 2024 tester
directement les épreuves et aussi
rencontrer les athlètes et ce soir
d'ailleurs deux membres de l'équipe de
France sont présents pour cette tournée
il s'agit de Léo garoian sacré champion
du monde de BMX serait
U23 c'était l'été dernier du côté de
Nantes il y aura aussi Arthur Pilar
champion de France de BMX en 2021 une
soirée qui devrait débuter aux alentours
de 18h30 avec une prise de parole
plusieurs prises de parole même on peut
citer parmi les officiels la présence
d'Aurélie merle qui est directrice
exécutive des Sports de Paris 2024 ou
encore et de Michel calot le président
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
le programme ensuite et bien il y aura
des démonstrations tout d'abord de BMX
Race alors si vous êtes forte en anglais
si vous avez pratiqué l'anglais bah il
mixera et ça veut dire tout simplement
bah course de BMX c'est l'une des
épreuves justement de BMX qui sera au
programme de Paris 2024 ces épreuves se
dérouleront juste ici derrière moi sur
ce stade de BMX situé à proximité du
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les épreuves
les dates des épreuves c'est les
premiers et de août il y aura également
des démonstrations de BMX flott alors le
BMX flotte c'est l'une des branches du
BMX Freestyle malheureusement cette
branche du BMX Freestyle donc le BMX
flat ne sera pas elle présente aux JO de
Paris 2024 et enfin pour terminer la
soirée bien sûr des in itiations les
personnes présentes pour en cesser
directement à ses disciplines événement
devrait se terminer aux alentours de 23h
avec plusieurs animations et une
ambiance assurée par le DJ je sais pas
si on entend le micro mais il y a déjà
de la musique qui est présente ici sur
ce Stadium de BMX et j'aimerais terminer
Mathilde avec un chiffre 442 est-ce que
vous savez à quoi ça correspond Mathilde
il me semble que c'est le nombre de
jours avant le lancement des jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024
bravo il y aura le quiz tout à l'heure
assuré par Nicolas dandry bah on peut
déjà vous donner un bon point le quiz
qui sera pas sur ce sujet mais
effectivement on est aujourd'hui donc à
442 jours de ce début et des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 merci beaucoup
Grégory canalet vous allez tester cette
piste du BMX ou pas
alors malheureusement j'ai pas prévu
j'ai pas prévu ma tenue pour faire une
initiation ce soir mais on va essayer à
d'ici la fin de cette émission d'aller
interroger quelques-uns des acteurs
présents pourquoi pas l'un des athlètes
présents sur cette soirée de la tournée
olympique lycée au stade de BMX on vous
retrouverez alors peut-être tout à
l'heure merci encore une nouvelle fois
Grégory canal et pour toutes ces
précisions enfin démission on le disait
à l'instant ne manquez pas le
traditionnel quiz du jeudi mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le temps devrait rester dégagé sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à Houdan
et Rambouillet et 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles dans
l'après-midi la pluie fera son
apparition dans les Yvelines
attendez-vous à quelques averses côté
température comptez environ 14 à 15
degrés en moyenne et demain nous
fêterons la saint Achille le point
maintenant sur les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Régina ralech on
commence avec cette information ce jeudi
les Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 on en
parle une nouvelle fois initie leur
deuxième phase de vente des billets et
oui Mathilde est justement suite à une
première phase difficile notamment à
cause de prix jugés excessifs et du
système de vente par pack les billets
sont désormais vendus à l'unité et
concernant les prix il varie selon le
sport les sessions et le placement ils
peuvent démarrer à 24 euros et vont
jusque 2700 euros et alors si on ne peut
pas acheter ces billets maintenant
comment ça se passe et bien écoutez
c'est ce n'est pas grave il restera
encore une troisième phase de vente qui
s'ouvrira fin de l'année plus de 3
millions de places seront avant mais
attention cette fois il n'y aura pas de
tirage au sort la vente se fera selon le
principe du premier arrivé premier
services
et puis on prend maintenant la direction
des Mureaux avec la visite du ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer Gérald
Darmanin après la saisie de 2,4 tonnes
de résine de cannabis hier matin dans la
ville le ministre a souhaité remercier
les policiers on l'écoute en quelques
jours ils ont réussi en effet à faire la
saisie quasiment la plus record de ces
30 dernières années en ce qui concerne
le cannabis en ce qui concerne une
enquête si j'ose dire quotidienne et je
pense que c'est grâce au renforcement
des des moyens bien sûr qu'on donne à la
police nationale les moyens techniques
mais aussi à l'abnégation des policiers
notamment des policiers qui travaillent
dans la discrétion et arrivent à saisir
2,4 tonnes en effet de cannabis pour une
valeur marchande de plus de 20 millions
d'euros
on continue ces informations du jour
avec ce chiffre 22000 consultations
médicales sont perdus chaque semaine
dans les Yvelines et c'est le chiffre du
jour l'ordre des médecins du département
sonne l'alarme en moyenne 7% des
rendez-vous sont annulés par les
patients chez les généralistes et chez
les spécialistes et le constat empire
dans le milieu hospitaliers qui observe
près de 15% des consultations non
honorées chaque semaine pour le
président de l'Ordre des médecins des
Yvelines ces dispositions des
dispositions pardon doivent être prises
afin de lutter contre je cite ce fléau
en août en constante augmentation et on
va maintenant parler de piscine régime
oui et même s'il est température ne sont
pas encore au beau fixe dans le nord des
Yvelines si piscine seront accessibles
pour 1 euro le 19 mai prochain et on
parle plus spécifiquement de certains
bassins imaginés à la fin des années 70
dans les villes de Poissy Les Mureaux
Verneuil Andrésy et de Porcheville alors
ces dernières n'ont pas de toboggan ni
dedans à remous ou encore de plongeoir
mais elles attirent encore notamment
pour leur batterie et leur faible
fréquentation de quoi faire le bonheur
des plus petits tout de même à
l'approche du Festival de Cannes la SPA
elle aussi fait son cinéma exactement et
ça se passera les 13 et 14 mai prochain
les 63 refuges et maison spa de France
organise un temps fort pour favoriser
l'adoption responsable et comme vous
l'avez dit à l'approche du Festival de
Cannes les refuges se mettront dans le
temps la SPA lance un jeu concours et
invite les internautes à proposer leur
propre idée d'affiche avec leur animal
de compagnie des premières affiches ont
déjà été partagées on les regarde
alors moi j'ai quand même une petite
préférence sur la la celle du milieu le
lapin ouais parce que c'est une affiche
qui a été faite en famille donc c'est
assez intéressant
voilà et alors du coup pour conclure
donc les Yvelines compte 4
établissements de la SPA à plaisir à
Orgeval et à Hermeray et puis on termine
les informations du jour avec un autre
événement ce week-end les golfeurs ont
rendez-vous à plaisir c'est la première
édition du Trophée de la ville qui se
tiendra au golf Isabella et 80
participants sont attendus merci
beaucoup Régine Radet pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 close
dès demain jusqu'à dimanche prochain
Epone accueillera un événement national
pour la première fois le Stadium Julien
Absalon recevra la Coupe de France 2 VTT
Trial 2023 une compétition de haut
niveau pour 150 des meilleurs pilotes
français et étrangers un moment
historique pour la communauté
[Musique]
il y a quelques temps nous avons
inauguré ce stade avec la venue du
vice-président monsieur jacotté qui est
venu ici qui était impressionné
justement par la qualité de ces
installations et avec la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme ils nous ont
proposé nous avons bien sûr accepté
d'organiser une étape de la Coupe de
France de VTT Trial
[Musique]
il y aura à partir de 8h les
compétitions jusqu'à 20h avec bien sûr
des podiums qui seront étalonnés tout au
long de la journée et entre ces podiums
et ses différentes épreuves des
démonstrations de breakdance
on va parler des peaux un peu partout en
France et même à l'international parce
qu'on aura des pilotes bien entendu les
leads françaises des pilotes mais on
aura aussi des pilotes internationaux
donc on va faire rayonner d'une part ce
stade Julien salon mais par la même
rayonner toute la ville d'Épône
[Musique]
voir un
pilote sur la roue arrière à 2 m du sol
sur des obstacles comme ça et faire des
sauts extraordinaires je veux dire c'est
on voit pas ça tous les jours et on a
peut-être vu une fois ou l'autre à la
télévision mais quand on le voit en
réalité qu'on est au pied d'un parce
qu'on sera au contact direct avec ces
pilotes
[Musique]
on en parlait en début de cette émission
chaque année Pôle Emploi mène une
enquête sur les besoins en main d'oeuvre
au niveau régional et départementale
dans les Yvelines 28% des établissements
envisagent de recruter cette année pour
en parler avec nous Philippe cample
directeur territorial pour Pôle Emploi
Yvelines tout à l'heure vous nous parlez
des secteurs qui recrutent le plus cette
année on a parlé de l'agriculture du
domaine de la construction ou de
l'industrie manufacturière ou encore du
service ce sont des secteurs qui ont
aussi du mal à embaucher est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
alors pourquoi il y a plusieurs
plusieurs motifs il peut y avoir du
déficit d'image par exemple de
l'entreprise du secteur du métier aussi
quand on parle de la construction bien
souvent on pense à des travaux pénibles
être à l'extérieur on sait aujourd'hui
que les méthodes de travail ont évolué
et donc c'est plus tout à fait la
réalité
on a la même position de travail
n'attire plus autant les conditions de
travail n'attire plus autant je pense
que la crise sanitaire est passée par là
aussi et puis les gens les personnes ont
envie de donner un peu de sens aussi à
ce qu'il a ce qu'ils font même si on
peut penser que construire des maisons
construire des immeubles ça ça a du sens
puisque c'est logé quand même les les
habitants
on a aussi dans les dans les
problématiques si on pense à la sécurité
bien souvent la sécurité on se dit bah
c'est des emplois précaires c'est pas
forcément du temps plein c'est pas
forcément du CDI ce qui est aujourd'hui
totalement faux on est sur un secteur
qui recherche beaucoup de monde on parle
de 20 à 25000 personnes à recruter
d'autant plus qu'on a à la coupe du
monde de rugby 2023 qui arrive à
l'automne et puis les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 et on a aussi voilà
du coup beaucoup de difficultés à
orienter les personnes donc ce qui veut
dire aujourd'hui que on a un problème
d'attractivité mais c'est pas spécifique
à tel ou telle secteur globalement une
problématique d'attractivité ce qui veut
dire que nous devons nous faire
découvrir les métiers alors bien entendu
en collaboration avec les entreprises
faire découvrir les métiers ou une
demandeur d'emploi qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas attirés par ces métiers donc
vous parlez de 25000 postes à pourvoir
dans le secteur des services c'est
c'est ce sont des CDI ce sont des CDD
c'est quel type de poste de la sécurité
principalement c'est de c'est c'est du
CDI mais globalement c'est environ 70%
d'emploi durable et quand on parle
d'emploi durable on parle de CD de CDD
supérieur à 6 mois ou de ou de CDI et
alors d'après ventre votre enquête vous
estimez également que près de deux tiers
des projets de recrutement annoncés sont
jugés difficiles sur le territoire
comment interpréter ce chiffre c'est un
manque d'attractivité de notre
territoire alors c'est pas le territoire
c'est ce sont les métiers en général qui
posent problème d'attractivité quand on
parle d'aide ménagère d'aide à domicile
on parlait on parlait de la sécurité on
parle des métiers du bâtiment
travailler dans la restauration dans
l'hôtellerie bah oui c'est des horaires
en décalé c'est parfois des coupures on
voit bien aussi aujourd'hui que les
établissements de restauration
s'accommodent aussi à cette difficulté
et aujourd'hui soit ils ont les moyens
de faire plusieurs équipes soit ils
ferment pour que les gens puissent aussi
avoir deux jours de jours de repos il y
a aussi eu des revalorisations de
salaire dans la restauration dans la
sécurité dont on parlait tout à l'heure
voilà tout le monde doit aussi faire un
effort pour rendre attractif les métiers
qui sont proposés aujourd'hui et alors
quels sont les métiers les plus
recherchés aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines
dans les Yvelines aujourd'hui les
métiers les plus recherchés on a les
aides à domicile les aménagères on a les
agents d'entretien on a tout ce qui
concerne la restauration alors que ce
soit les employés polygdollants de
cuisine mais aussi les aides les commis
des apprentis aussi du conseil que on
passe aussi beaucoup par par
l'apprentissage on a tout ce qui
concerne les métiers de la santé les
aides-soignants les infirmières par
exemple
dans la restauration tout ce qui est
serveur aussi qui est très recherché on
a aussi du secrétariat les employés de
libre-service dans le dans le commerce
et puis après tout ce qui est lié à
l'informatique les ingénieurs en
recherche et développement ou sur le
département et sur le bassin de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
beaucoup d'emplois sur l'informatique
aux personnes qui sont inscrites à Pôle
emploi pour les amener vers ce type de
métier alors pour tous les métiers qui
recrutent les métiers en tension
effectivement on a des dispositifs de
formation soit financés par la Région
soit financer par par Pôle Emploi
lorsqu'on est sur quelques compétences
qui manquent on peut avant le
recrutement par l'entreprise financé
jusqu'à 400 heures de formation pour ces
demandeurs d'emploi afin que lorsque la
personne arrive dans l'entreprise elle
est les compétences recherchée et du
coup tous ces tous ces métiers ça
représente combien de postes à pourvoir
alors sur le département pour 2023
l'enquête prévoit 43 000 projets de
recrutement
merci beaucoup Philippe d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je le rappelle vous
êtes le directeur territorial de Pôle
Emploi Yvelines et si vous souhaitez
connaître toutes les données de cette
enquête sur les besoins en main d'oeuvre
en Île-de-France et dans les Yvelines
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran et tout de suite on retrouve
Grégory canalet au Stadium BMX de 50
in-en-yvelines
oui Mathilde et je suis en compagnie de
Michel calloul le président de la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir à tous Alors c'est déjà
la deuxième fois que vous accueillez
cette tournée des sites olympiques je le
disais tout à l'heure lors du premier
duplex il y avait eu le lancement tout
simplement de cet événement c'est Tony
storia qui était venu ici en avril 2022
pour la tournée au sein du vélo de route
ça fait quoi de recevoir la proximité
directe de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme je me rappelle que les locaux
sont implantés dans une autre drone
national de recevoir justement cet
événement c'est une immense satisfaction
parce que ça nous fait vibrer encore
plus fort par rapport à la perspective
des Jeux ça concrétise quand même
quelque chose qui est parfois difficile
à réaliser qu'on va avoir ici sur ces
terrains-là les Jeux Olympiques dans 442
jours justement et puis c'est un teneur
quand même pour la Fédération Française
de cycliste de pouvoir présenter à
travers ses athlètes ces sites qui vont
devenir olympique on a un vélo de drone
on le sait de premier rang au niveau
international est-ce que il en est de
même pour cette piste de BMX oui c'est
une piste qui a acc une coupe du monde
notamment donc le plus haut niveau
international on est sur du top niveau
c'est un outil qui permet à nos athlètes
de se préparer tous les jours avec tout
ce qu'il faut à la fois pour pouvoir
accueillir la compétition et pour
pouvoir également diversifier les
entraînements il y avait des
incertitudes quant à l'organisation
notamment liée au toit là tout est clair
d'ici c'est 442 jours qui nous séparent
de l'ouverture des JO les épreuves de
BMX se Racing se déroulant les premiers
et de route ici à 50 ans de vie
absolument il y avait des choix
techniques à opérer ils ont été tranchés
sur chaque sujet maintenant on sait
qu'il y aura une rénovation de la piste
malgré tout et un Test Event qui
permettra de mesurer que tout est bien
en place dans le printemps 2024 mais la
configuration du site restera ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui alors du côté des
chances françaises pour le BMX alors ce
soir il y a deux des représentants de
l'équipe de France il y a léo-garouan
qui est récent champion du Monde du 23
de BMX Racing également Arthur Pilar qui
a déjà eu titre de champion d'Europe de
BMX est-ce que c'est de là sont
susceptibles d'être dans cette équipe de
France en 2024 oui ils font partie
effectivement des athlètes qui sont
sélectionnables sans aucun doute avec
quelques autres quand même parce que
c'est le gros avantage notamment chez
les garçons on a une très forte densité
on a en tous les cas cinq ou six pilotes
qui régulièrement sont plus au niveau
mondial alors déjà ils vont se disputer
les sélections entre eux et puis affirmé
je l'espère en tous les cas leur
présence pendant toutes les compétitions
qui nous restent jusqu'aux Jeux
Olympiques au plus haut niveau mondial
est-ce que vous espérez battre la
dernière malédiction ici à Paris 2024 on
rappelle que pour la finale homme de BMX
Racing lors des derniers Jeux de Tokyo
il y avait trois Français engagés en
finale sur 7 au final pas de pas de
médailles on espère remporter une
médaille quand même sur sur ces JO alors
on est des sportifs on a franchement là
une revanche à prendre ça a été une
claque il y a pas d'autres mots pour
pour le cyclisme français et pour nous
tous voilà on se donne les moyens on
travaille avec le pilote avec leur
encadrement on fait
que tu penses un travail de fond
important pour appréhender cet événement
dans les bonnes conditions
psychologiques et effectivement avoir
une vraie revanche sur nos adversaires
on sera bien sûr tous derrière cette
équipe de France je rappelle donc que
cette tournée des sites olympiques va
débuter aux alentours de 18h30 d'ici 10
minutes avec des démonstrations des
initiations et donc je le rappelle je
t'ai en compagnie de Michel calot le
président de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
on va continuer de parler de vélo
puisque mes deux vélos moins sportifs
puisque c'est attitude vélo attitude qui
va arriver à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce samedi 13 mai
c'est avec vous qu'on en parle Jérémy
joggler conseiller municipal en charge
du développement de la pratique du vélo
pour la commune ça se passera au gymnase
Coubertin de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
alors cette journée Jérémy jugulé va
s'articuler autour de quatre thématiques
on a je m'informe je découvre je
m'équipe et j'entretiens oui tout à fait
alors on on voit bien à travers les
différents reportages déjà que les
Yvelines sont une terre de vélo
moi mon rôle là-dedans c'est de
développer la pratique pour les
habitants de Montigny et des alentours
de 50 ans en Yvelines et donc au bout de
trois ans de mandat on a vu qu'il
fallait apporter des réponses concrètes
aux habitants aux questions qui se
posent donc il se pose de questions pour
quelles sont les itinéraires cyclables
comment je puis je peux protéger mon
vélo comment je dois m'équiper comment
je dois réparer entretenir mon vélo et
donc ce sont toutes ces thématiques que
l'on a regroupées dans un événement à
Pierre de Coubertin avec nos partenaires
donc les institutionnels vivent
agglomération départements et toutes nos
associations qui sont formidables et qui
œuvrent au quotidien avec nous la
pratique du vélo est très importante à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux oui j'espère
qu'elle sera de plus en plus
on a la chance enfin on a la chance
c'est un travail de de longue haleine
d'avoir été de deuxième au baromètre des
villes cyclables donc ça c'est un
baromètre national qui est dans lequel
de chacun peut répondre et moi Montigny
et deuxième maison que ça sachant que la
première est Versailles
et une grosse ville c'est une grosse
ville dans les Yvelines donc ça confirme
bien les Yvelines comme terre de vélo et
donc là dedans on voit qu'il y a une
vraie
infrastructure il y a des choses qui se
passent il y a des services qui sont
disponibles pour pour les habitants mais
nous ne savent pas encore et donc c'est
à travers cet événement qu'on peut les
faire venir pour qu'il découvre parce
que on a une enfin j'ai personnellement
une une conviction c'est à partir du
moment où on a essayé on va le pratiquer
et donc on va répondre aux questions et
on va pouvoir pratiquer il y aura des
vélos à disposition notamment les vélos
de la Vélo Station qui sont en location
normalement pour pouvoir essayer mais il
y aura aussi des vélos électriques où on
pourra faire une petite pratique et pour
vraiment compléter le dispositif on va
organiser avec notre partenaire du Vélo
Club de Montigny-le-Bretonneux des
balades des balades dans tout pour
découvrir nos pistes cyclables les
trajets sécurisés et donc d'essayer
d'essayer c'est l'adopter et alors c'est
de plus en plus en vogue vous proposez
également un atelier de réparation de
vélo avec l'association vicyclette oui
tout à fait parce que le
notre démarche elle est évidemment
écologique tournée vers les mobilités
mais elle est également dans une
démarche sociale et de transmission donc
on a pu accueillir l'atelier la
bicyclette là depuis le depuis le 1er
juin à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ça marche
très très fort il y a 150 adhérents qui
se sont inscrits depuis le premier juin
l'objectif c'est de assurer la
transmission que chacun soit capable de
réparer son vélo de l'entretenir ses
freins sont des rayures sa chaîne ou
encore
réparer un pneu ou une chambre à air sur
ces images même notre journaliste Julien
Leroy a testé l'atelier de réparation
bicyclette comment ça se passe
concrètement concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'il faut savoir pour pouvoir bien
réparer son vélo est-ce qu'il y a il y a
trois choses importantes à connaître
pour entretenir son vélo
pour tenir alors vérifier ses freins
vérifier ses freins parce que ça c'est
très important vérifiez ces pneus et
puis
venir faire un tour à la bicyclette pour
voir comment comment on entretient sa
chaîne et donc en continuant cette
journée à la fin à partir de 20h vous
projetez le documentaire why oui cycle
pourquoi nous faisons du vélo en
français de quoi ça parle ce
documentaire alors la projection
débutera à 20h donc on va convier tout
le monde à partir de 19h30
là c'est aussi une volonté un peu plus
décalée de s'inspirer de ce qui se fait
ailleurs et donc why we Savoie c'est un
documentaire sur la société néerlandaise
qui nous explique d'où elle est partie
elle était tout voiture dans les années
70 il y a eu un événement marquant qui a
complètement retourné la société
peut-être que la transition écologique
sera notre événement marquant à nous et
qui à partir de là ils ont développé une
pratique du vélo et ce documentaire va
jusqu'à nous dire mais qu'est-ce que ça
apporte à l'individu et qu'est-ce que ça
apporte à la société comment on fait
société ensemble et comment la pratique
de cet objet tout banal le vélo
finalement change notre rapport à la
société j'ai envie de poser cette
question est-ce que vous faites beaucoup
de vélos Philippe camp Alison Laurent
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
faites au quotidien ou en loisir non la
marche la marche c'est bien aussi moi
pareil je suis plutôt marcheuse parce
que j'habite à 50 mètres de mon lieu de
travail donc le vélo c'est un peu
superflu par contre mon époux fait
énormément de vélo il se déplace par
exemple et l'enseigner à Lille et donc
il verra à vélo à l'égard du Nord pour
prendre le TGV par exemple Versailles
gare du Nord
donc on est plutôt convaincu c'est juste
que j'ai les moins besoin
je profite pour rebondir parce que c'est
ça ça va tout à fait dans le cadre de la
de l'initiative menée par la région des
RER vélo qui sont pour faciliter les
transitions jusqu'à Paris et entre
banlieue de développer des itinéraires
sécurisés est plutôt rapide et à
Montigny on a deux itinéraires qui
passent un qui vient de Paris Massy et
qui va aller jusqu'à plaisir et à cette
occasion on va développer une passerelle
au dessus de la de l'autoroute donc ça
c'est ça va arriver là dans les années à
venir et puis l'autre itinéraire qui
viendront bouillir et qui va aller
jusqu'à Paris pour pour faire ce RER
vélo et donc là toute la collectivité
enfin toutes les collectivités que ça
soit la région l'agglomération le
département et la ville on est
complètement mobilisés pour développer
ses itinéraires et bien merci beaucoup
Jérémy jongler d'avoir accepté notre
invitation si vous êtes intéressé la
vélo attitude c'est ce samedi au Centre
sportif Pierre de Coubertin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux de 14h à 18h
l'après-midi sera suivie de la
projection d'un documentaire et d'une
table ronde à partir de 19h30 pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet de Montigny 78.fr
direction Houilles à présent une
yvelinoise a été approchée par célèbre
concours international Bertille hurar
artiste verrier a eu la surprise d'être
contactée par les équipes de
l'Eurovision l'objet de la demande de la
réalisation de quatre trophées pour un
concours interne entre les membres de
l'organisation bien que c'est œuvres ne
soient pas destinées à la diffusion
télévisée la créatrice nous a tout de
même livré sa fierté le reportage de
Julien Leroy une artiste verriez
yvelinoise a fait briller le révision
cette créatrice passionnée par la
couleur et la lumière à installer son
atelier à Houilles en 2004 vitro Vaz ou
sculpture font partie de ces
réalisations en parallèle confectionne
des trophées pour de grandes sociétés ou
des événements sportifs approchés par
les équipes du célèbre concours de chant
international elle recevait fin février
une commande pour une remise de prix la
prise de contact était par mail comme
souvent avec les entreprises en fait ils
avaient contacté une entreprise
apparemment qui fait des trophées entre
guillemets plus standardisés et qui ont
dit non contacté cette personne
puisqu'il faut vraiment du sur-mesure
l'artisan disposait d'un délai de trois
semaines pour achever son travail dans
un premier temps elle imaginait des
oeuvres destinées à la diffusion
télévisée mais un atelier suédois était
en charge du projet ses créations
finalement servi à un concours interne
entre les salariés de l'Eurovision la
dimension m'a semblé petite pour un
trophée de finale qui devait se voir sur
une estrade de loin et le fait qu'il en
est quatre aussi il m'a un petit peu
intrigué grâce à une photo du rendu
désiré elle s'est lancée dans la
réalisation la créatrice a dessiné ses
propres croquis pour les quatre micros
en verre de 20 cm c'était chouette à
faire c'était bien c'est toujours un
petit peu un challenge parce qu'il y
avait des questions techniques à
résoudre dans un pour que ça ressemble à
ce qu'il souhaitait et puis il y a une
pression parce qu'on nous dit mince là
il faut pas se louper donc je les ai
bien soignés
surprise par sa récente exposition
médiatique elle reçoit dorénavant de
nombreuses félicitations des habitants
de quoi espérer sa participation au
Trophée de la finale l'année prochaine
et nous avons été rejoints plateau par
deux journalistes de la rédaction de TV
78 Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir Mathieu
Nicolas dandry bonsoir également alors
Gabriel Gontier avec vous on va voir vos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines pour
ce week-end rapidement vous allez nous
parler de toi de plein de choses très
différentes on va commencer par une
exposition de dinosaures à grandeur
réelle c'est une exposition immersive je
vous en parlerai dans quelques instants
donc ce sera dans quelques instants en
fin d'émission Nicolas vous vous allez
nous challenger avec le quiz ce sera sur
quoi ce soir alors je tiens d'abord à
remercier Grégory canalet et Régine
rallès d'avoir pris le relais de ce quiz
et d'avoir animé ce quiz traditionnel du
jeudi et puis ce soir on va parler de
l'Union européenne dans les Yvelines
pourquoi parce que le 9 mai c'est bien
c'était mardi et bien c'était la journée
de l'Union européenne la Journée de
l'Europe
à vos questions tout à l'heure en fin
d'émission également et puis on a été
aussi rejoint par ATIS Barret bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde alors vous un peu comme
d'habitude le jeudi vous venez vous
présenter votre chronique sur le
bien-être animal et alors j'ai un petit
indice sur la table ce soir vous allez
nous parler de moutons de la tente des
moutons voilà je ne viens jamais les
mains vides je vais vous parler
maintenant de mouton et bien ce sera
juste après mais avant on va parler de
mode ECO responsable la ville de
Versailles se met à la mode
éco-responsable dimanche 14 mai 11
créateurs de bijoux d'accessoires et de
vêtements proposeront un défilé de mode
éco-responsable à l'hôtel de ville de
Versailles à l'initiative de ce projet
Alison Laurent créatrice de mode pour
kentuki Rennes à Versailles Alison
Laurent ce n'est pas la première fois
que vous êtes à l'initiative d'un défilé
de mode éco-responsable pourquoi c'est
important pour vous il faut sensibiliser
les gens sur cette question il faut
sensibiliser les gens les
l'industrie de la mode est extrêmement
polluant les Doigts de l'Homme sont
totalement bafoués aussi on en parle
énormément actuellement avec
ultra face fashion qui ouvre des
magasins à Paris
c'est dramatique il faut vraiment qu'on
change de mode de consommation donc ça
fait longtemps que je travaille dans la
mode éco-responsable et je me rends
compte qu'il y a une sensibilité du
public qui est de plus en plus présente
à cette question mais il y a beaucoup de
gens qui n'osent pas passer le cap et
pensent que c'est trop difficile c'est
que la mode éco-responsable c'est
qu'on sera tout de suite que c'est je
sais pas c'est plus difficile à porter
que c'est difficile à trouver que c'est
trop cher donc il y a beaucoup de
raisons pour lesquelles il faut
sensibiliser les publics après ça va
être de manière générale les marques
aujourd'hui de mode etc responsables
sont quand même beaucoup plus cher en
tout cas que les marques fashion en
effet parce que c'est pas accessible à
tout le monde donc comment faire pour
que ça devienne progressivement
accessible pour tous alors il faut
comprendre aussi que cette différence de
prix est basée sur la réalité
le coût de travail en France par exemple
c'est beaucoup plus cher qu'en Chine
surtout quand en Chine on peut aussi
utiliser le travail un peu forcé donc
forcément ça va être plus cher il faut
que les gens acceptent le fait de payer
un peu plus cher pour un produit de
meilleure qualité qui est réalisée dans
le respect de la planète et de l'homme
par contre ce sont les pièces donc
justement de meilleure qualité qu'on va
pouvoir garder plus longtemps et donc
infinie on fait des économies et alors
pour revenir sur ce défilé de mode
éco-responsable c'est avec 11 créateurs
comment est-ce que vous les avez choisi
rencontrer sélectionner ça s'est passé
comment alors ça fait des années que je
propose un partenariat à la mairie pour
faire un
projet ce que moi je trouvais culturel
et écologique et ils ont accepté cette
année un mode collectif donc j'ai lancé
un appel à candidature qui a duré un peu
plus d'un mois était ouvert tout type de
créateurs bijoux accessoires et
vêtements il y avait une charte assez
précise pour que ce soit et qu'on
responsable donc minimum fabrication
française et en plus une autre démarche
supplémentaire
éco-responsable ça pourrait être du
obsolin du circuit court du bio sourcing
il y a beaucoup de façon en fait d'être
éco-responsable peut-être juste rappeler
rapidement ce que c'est l'obsideline
l'obscling c'est de prendre un objet qui
est en fin de vie un vêtement un textile
de maison et de lui redonner une
nouvelle vie en le rendant meilleur
quelque part alors c'est un peu
difficile à
qualifier ce qui est meilleur mais de
façon générale
ça va devenir des pièces uniques très
souvent donc déjà en soi c'est pas mal
et alors chacun de ces créateurs ont une
sensibilité différente quelque chose qui
les démarque par rapport aux autres
alors on a tous des styles assez variés
la seule chose en commun c'est vraiment
cette envie de rendre notre impact sur
la planète aussi peu
polluante que possible et donc vous vous
êtes venus avec vos créations est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu
comment comment est-ce que vous les avez
créé justement alors mon haut par
exemple c'était avant c'était une robe
dont le haut était abîmé parce que
c'était dans une sorte tulle et ça avait
subi un trou de cigarettes je pense donc
c'est éliminé le haut j'ai gardé le bas
pour faire le haut là et le col de
souvenirs c'était une jupe pareil qui
avait des trous de mythe parce que c'est
dans une
crêpe de laine et c'est vrai que même
les pièces dont on tombe bien soin
parfois ça peut avoir des petits partis
abîmées donc moi je limite des parties
abîmées et j'ai créé quelque chose ne
faisait du coup des vêtements qui sont
uniques où vous arrivez à produire
plusieurs modèles complètement nids
alors j'ai des modèles que je répète ce
type de haut je le répète assez souvent
mais c'est chaque fois dans ces matières
différentes tissus différentes dans les
tailles différentes voilà c'est la force
pardon de votre marque c'est de d'avoir
une pièce unique ce sont des pièces
uniques et je dis toujours pourquoi on
s'habille tous pareil parce que nous
sommes tous différents et vous utilisez
uniquement des vêtements des anciens
vêtements où vous prenez par exemple du
tissu des rideaux des nations
et réaliser alors dans un coupon qui n'a
jamais servi pour le coup c'était un
coupon qui datait des années 80 qui
était destiné à faire des rideaux mais
j'utilise très souvent de linge de
maison des rideaux lors du défilé il y
aura un tableau qui est dont il sous
tous les silhouettes sont blancs et
c'est réalisé surtout à partir des draps
anciens qui sont à l'époque fabriqués en
France très belle qualité et qui reste
encore de très belles qualités et ça
c'est l'intérêt de ces TEX qu'on
récupère dans le temps
c'est là et on peut encore utiliser
alors que le textile qu'on produit
actuellement il y a toujours au moins 3%
de l'élasthanne dedans ça lui est très
très mal et ce sont les textiles qu'on
pourra pas utiliser pendant très très
longtemps et alors malgré l'installation
de grande marque chinoises à Paris qui
ont fait polémique récemment est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'on avance
petit à petit quand même sur sur cette
question de mode éco-responsable et
qu'on va vers une consommation d'habits
de vêtements
moins moins polluants oui il y a il y a
du progrès
donc ça fait presque 20 ans que je
travaille là-dedans seulement 16 ans de
mon atelier boutique à Versailles et
c'est vrai que au départ je ne pouvais
pas tellement
je pouvais pas expliquer aussi
clairement ma démarche parce qu'il y a
il y avait des
idées un peu fixes c'était
c'est pas propre c'est voilà je pouvais
parler des tissus vintage parce que ça
c'était déjà dans l'air du temps mais
maintenant je peux vraiment parler du
fait que ça a eu une vie
ultérieure antérieure et que
c'est pour moi va leur ajouter de savoir
qu'il y a une passé une histoire et que
cette histoire va continuer et sous une
autre forme et bien merci beaucoup
Alison Laurent d'avoir accepté notre
invitation si vous souhaitez vous rendre
à ce défilé de mode éco-responsable ça
se passe à 15h 15h45 15h45 15h45 ce
dimanche 14 mai à l'hôtel de ville de
Versailles l'entrée est libre et
entièrement gratuite allez de la mode on
va parler maintenant de bien-être animal
puisque c'est l'heure de la chronique au
poil avec à Tiz barré
[Musique]
alors je le rappelle l'artiste Barret
vous êtes conseiller un municipal en
charge du bien-être animal pour la ville
de Poissy et ce soir vous allez nous
parler de la tonte des moutons
exactement soit je vais vous parler de
bien-être animal avec la tonte des
moutons les moutons ne pas et ils ont
besoin de l'intervention de l'homme pour
l'aider à se refaire une peau neuve et
donc c'est à cette période de l'année
qu'on commence à tondre les moutons oui
alors en fait la tombe des moutons a
lieu une seule fois dans l'année et donc
c'est au mois d'avril au mois de mai au
mois d'avril on te découvre pas d'un fil
mais au mois de mai c'est un petit
rappel mais
n'oubliez pas de faire la tente de vos
moutons puisque c'est très indispensable
pour la santé de nos moutons
la laine donc le mouton en fait il
produit 3 à 5 kg de laine par an cet
oiseau elle va être épaisse elle sera
remplie de pailles comme vous pouvez le
constater de crottin le mouton il va
produire du soin de la graisse qui est
sécrétée par la peau et donc c'est
vraiment indispensable pour lui de
qu'on lui effectue sa tonte oui ça va
permettre plusieurs choses notamment au
niveau des maladies puis aussi du
troupeau tout à fait donc ça va
permettre d'assainir le troupeau de
limiter les maladies et puis le mouton
lui va se sentir plus léger ça va
stimuler également son appétit les
agneaux vont pouvoir téter les mamelles
de leur maman également pour la mise à
bas de ça va être plus simple ça va le
mouton bah il va pouvoir mettre à bas
tranquillement et ça ira moins de
risques de s'étouffer et puis la tonte
également elle n'est pas douloureuse
elle va permettre d'inspecter votre
mouton voire est-ce qu'il est maigre
est-ce qu'il avait besoin de soin et
alors à quoi va servir toute cette laine
après alors cette laine on a parlé de
Fashion éco-responsable on est bien dans
le thème donc va servir en fait depuis
deux ans et demi moi je m'en sers grâce
aux agents déjà de la ville de Poissy je
la récupère pour en faire derrière déjà
les parties qui sont en crottées des en
servir au jardin au niveau des potagers
donc pour faire du paillage et les
parties qui sont propres elles seront
lavées et ben ma maman qui couturière
elle elle s'en sert donc les elles on
les lave au niveau de la terrasse et il
en ressort comme ça des coussins et là
voilà on peut faire des doudous ça c'est
mon doudou à moi on peut en faire des
doudous pour les bébés d'ailleurs en
félicite notre Mickaël pour la minute de
son bébé on lui fera peut-être un petit
doudou pourquoi pas oui c'est une bonne
idée et on s'en sert aussi on peut voir
peut-être bien sûr
j'en ai un sac rempli
du fromage
mais c'est pas un odeur désagréable mais
ça semble naturel ça sent naturel si on
doit décrire l'odeur c'est l'odeur de la
ferme franchement si on rentre dans une
étable c'est l'odeur qu'on peut dormir
Michael je peux je peux vous rassurer
Mickaël c'est très doux c'est très doux
c'est bon aussi pour les articulations
pour il y a de la présence de l'anoline
à l'intérieur donc pour nos chroniqueurs
sportifs qui font trop de sport j'en
laisserai aussi j'ai tout un sac rempli
j'ai pas tout sorti sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
j'en profite pour remercier donc nos
agents de la ville de Poissy puisqu'il
hier ils nous ont ouvert les portes on a
pu faire la tonte ils nous ont alors ils
ont mis les moutons à l'aise la tente
était vraiment magnifique puis ils nous
ont mis à l'aise aussi moi j'étais plus
stressée que que des moutons
je remercie donc Alexis Guillot Monsieur
Serge lesoufres Carl cousin madame Irène
Perrault bien sûr madame le Maire sandre
et dos Santos nous avoir autorisé à
venir tourner merci à Nicolas d'être
venu pour les images très belle matinée
effectivement
faut bien insister là dessus les moutons
ne souffrent pas au moment de la tonte
alors c'est vrai qu'il se débattent un
peu parce que la position n'est pas
évidente pour eux mais c'est vraiment
pour leur santé et puis il y a vraiment
une technique et Mathilde vous souvenez
sûrement qu'on avait fait on avait
participé à une formation justement au
berger à la Bergerie Nationale
et on voit que hier les agents ont été
formés à ça et qui prennent vraiment
l'attention pour bien positionner le
mouton et faire attention
il y a de la technique
et on avait également la présence de
l'élu de champlo qui était là hier soir
hier à Madame Sophie Chergui que je
remercie elle était venue pouvoir
l'agneau Louise Louise qui s'était perdu
dans les roues dans les rues de
Chanteloup et cet agneau a été recueilli
par laminifère de Poissy et il me semble
que vous vouliez dire un petit mot sur
sur les cochons d'inde par rapport à la
semaine dernière la semaine dernière
Mathilde nous avons parlé des cochons
d'Inde on a eu un fort succès d'ailleurs
il y a l'association Les Petites
patachons du 59 qui nous regardent de
Maroilles alors déjà je passe mes
salutations je les félicite pour le très
beau travail qui font pour l'adoption
des cochons d'Inde et je vous laisse
souligner à nouveau qu'il faut bien
adopter vos animaux à la SPA je ne le
souligne pas assez parce que pour moi
c'est une évidence de passer à la SPA ou
beaucoup d'animaux vous attendent ils
recherchent des familles beaucoup
d'amour et du bonheur et puisque vous
appréciez l'émission la chronique
bien-être animal ce qu'on commence à
avoir pas mal de messages n'hésitez pas
continuer à nous envoyer des mails avec
vos suggestions et les sujets que vous
souhaitez voir et bien merci beaucoup
Baptiste barrée pour tous vos précieux
conseils on vous retrouve prochainement
pour pour une nouvelle chronique pour
une nouvelle chronique très
prochainement donc on verra de quoi vous
allez nous parler plus tard c'est ça
peut-être de votre chat Mathilde ah
d'accord peut-être de mon chat
allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une page
loisirs à présent
[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel comme
chaque jeudi à l'approche du week-end
vous nous présenter vos meilleurs plans
pour pour passer un bon temps dans les
Yvelines on commence par quoi ce soir et
bien je vous propose pour commencer le
week-end une exposition inédite en
France ça se passe aux Clayes-sous-Bois
la ville accueille samedi une trentaine
de dinosaures robotisés une exposition
immersive avec des dinosaures à tailleur
réel accompagné d'une ambiance sonore au
delà du spectacle l'exposition à une
visée pédagogique des animations vont
être proposées comme des ateliers de
fouilles archéologiques ou encore la
projection d'un documentaire une
exposition à la fois familiale et
instructive c'est à découvrir jusqu'au
21 mai samedi un autre événement risque
de nous donner des frissons cette fois
pas de bon dans le temps avec les
dinosaures mais plutôt dans le ciel car
tout se passe au-dessus de nos têtes oui
et même à plusieurs mètres au-dessus de
nos têtes Mathilde samedi a lieu une
démonstration de Highline alors je sais
pas si autour du plateau vous savez ce
que c'est alors
et en effet ça fait peur pour vous c'est
quoi et c'est marcher sur quelque chose
pas très large exactement il s'agit de
cette discipline que certains d'entre
vous ont dû déjà voir une discipline
sportive qui consiste à marcher sur un
fil à plusieurs mètres du sol en effet
c'est pas très large la démonstration se
fera au-dessus de l'écoquartier du parc
du lac de Voisins le bretonneux pour
assurer le spectacle Lucas Giovanni
Moraira recordman mondial de la plus
longue traversée en 2021 on regarde
quelques images de sa performance au
dessus des glaciers d'Argentière des
images vous allez le voir assez
impressionnante
[Musique]
bon alors je sais pas si ça vous a donné
envie en tout cas pour les plus
téméraires d'entre vous de 14 à 18h des
parcours d'initiation seront proposés
accessibles à tous en tout cas c'était
de très belles images on prend
maintenant la direction de Noisy-le-Roi
pour le salon des créateurs et des
artistes Gabriel oui c'est la 6e édition
du salon qui reprend ses quartiers dans
les anciennes écuries de Noisy-le-Roi
alors au programme samedi et dimanche de
10h à 19h à 18 exposants choisis pour
leur création parmi eux des peintres des
tisseurs d'argent ou encore des
maroquiniers pour Sophie fromo
l'organisatrice du salon il permet de
créer un dialogue entre artisans d'art
et artiste sur une même passion un même
point de départ ici ce point de départ
c'est la matière qui peut prendre
différentes formes selon la manière dont
elle est travaillée le but est également
de mettre en avant le savoir-faire
français et yvelinois la magie est mise
à l'honneur samedi soir à la Meurice de
Trappes oui après 30 ans de magie dans
les grandes salles de France et d'Europe
mais aussi sur les plateaux de
télévision dans le plus grand cabaret du
monde de Patrick Sébastien notamment
Dani Lary remonte sur scène à la Meuse
de Trappes au travers d'un spectacle
dont le titre comment faire disparaître
son père donne le ton dans cette
création plus intime il partage la scène
avec son fils Albert Larry au programme
de l'humour notamment sur le choc des
générations et bien sûr vous l'imaginez
beaucoup de magie on termine avec du
sport Gabriel du sport équestre et une
compétition à l'hippodrome de
Rambouillet oui je pense que ça va
particulièrement vous intéresser
Mathilde la quatrième étape du Trophée
verse déroule à Rambouillet ce dimanche
des trésors alors pour ceux qui ne sont
pas familiers il s'agit d'une
compétition annuelle de trop attelé en
14 étapes qui se déroulent dans toute la
France d'avril à septembre alors
dimanche c'est l'occasion pour les
passionnés et les curieux de venir
découvrir ou redécouvrir cette
discipline dans les Yvelines dont la
piste n'a pas été choisie au hasard
comme en témoigne ses archives que nous
avions tourné en 2014
la compétition mise en place en 2001 est
un circuit national sur 14 étapes sa
particularité toutes les pistes se
conjuguent au vert Rambouillet n'a pas
été choisi au hasard
professionnel je voyais des pistes en
herbe disparaître au fur et à mesure
bien avoir au profit de la création de
pistes en dur et du point de vue
professionnel c'était une erreur
monumentale parce que tout le monde
voulait une piste en dur comme charte
comme Laval comme quand
comme chaque année je non
comme chaque année ça revient la
dernière édition vous l'avez vu on l'a
filmé en 2014 et cette année elle
revient et vous je crois que vous voulez
finir par la Nuit européenne des musées
parlait un petit peu du programme dans
les Yvelines Gabriel exactement on en a
un petit peu parlé en début de semaine
ça revient cette année encore c'est le
cas du musée Lambinet de Versailles le
musée de la batellerie à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ou encore le
musée d'archéologie nationale de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye alors bien entendu
c'est une une liste pardon non
exhaustive vous pouvez vous rapprocher
des sites internet de vos musées
préférés des musées dans vos villes pour
découvrir leur programme pour l'occasion
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie je crois que
Gabriel en fait elle a été perturbée
parce que pendant l'extrait elle m'a
soufflé dans l'oreille c'est pas
Mathilde qu'on vient de voir à l'image
mais c'est pour ça que je crois qu'elle
était un peu partout
traditionnel petit tour de plateau
qu'est-ce qui vous tente le plus dans
toutes ces idées de sortie
et bien une très bonne question
européenne des musées
qui sont qui ont l'air plutôt pas mal
allez on poursuit avec votre quiz
Nicolas dandry alors ce soir vous allez
nous challenger sur l'Union européenne
dans les Yvelines
alors dans tous ces états on va voir et
bien la première question d'abord
première question regardez ces images la
question je dirais même les questions
sont simples ou quoi quoi qui ou quoi
qui
[Musique]
c'est ou quoi qui
vous laisse réfléchir encore il faut
écrire beaucoup là voilà c'est une voilà
ou quoi qui
alors est-ce qu'on peut voir les
réponses de chacun où je vous laisse un
peu plus de temps ah non non
si vous avez rien écrit vous pouvez
donner verbalement j'accepte les
réponses orales alors Léon Blum jouer en
Joseph maison Europe
[Musique]
que des mauvaises réponses je suis
désolé alors où nous étions à Bazoches
sur Guillaume
quoi c'était une maison et la maison de
Jean c'était la maison Jean Monnet alors
en fait Jean Monnet c'est le père
fondateur c'est l'un des pères
fondateurs des prémices de l'Union
européenne il est notamment à
l'initiative de la création de la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier puis de la création de la
Communauté européenne économique et deux
ratums suite à la signature du traité de
Rome le traité de Rome a été pensé dans
cette maison à Bazoches-sur-Guyonne et
Jean Monnet et décédé en 1979 dans cette
maison deuxième question est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire ce qui s'est passé le 27
mars
1957 le 27 mars 1957
le 25 non le 27 mars 25 mars pardon
autant pour moi deux jours avant le 27
mars le 25 mars 1957 qu'est-ce que c'est
passé
[Musique]
je dirais la création de l'Union
européenne alors non je veux plus de
précisions s'il vous plaît
signature de
du traité de Rome
bonne réponse de Mathilde Franco
effectivement alors plus précisément la
signature des traités de Rome des
Traités de Rome c'est l'acte fondateur
de ce qui ressemble le plus aujourd'hui
à l'Union européenne comme je l'ai dit
dans la réponse à la question précédente
il fallait bien écouter les Traités de
Rome crée la Communauté économique
européenne et euraum troisième question
nous allons parler des élus européens
plusieurs femmes et hommes politiques
originaires des Yvelines ont siéger ou
siège toujours au Parlement européen
aujourd'hui 3 euros députés sont ivinois
est-ce que vous pouvez me donner leur
nom regardez vous avez leur visage qui
s'affiche à l'écran
le nom des trois s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
effectivement il y avait aussi
François-Xavier Bellamy alors Mathilde
rouet euro député du rassemblement
national François-Xavier Bellamy qui est
euro député du Parti les républicains et
il y avait Mounir sa Touri qui est
taureau des député et Europe Écologie
Les Verts Mathilde un demi point quand
même je vous accorde
allez retour en mars 2022 au coeur de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne et un mois après le début de
l'invasion l'Ukraine par la Russie
Emmanuel Macron accueille les dirigeants
européens et des États membres au
château de Versailles un sommet européen
extraordinaire conclu par une conférence
de presse d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
vous pouvez me donner le nom des deux
personnes qui accompagnent Emmanuel
Macron lors de cette conférence de
presse s'il vous plaît
et je veux leur titre si vous avez leur
titre en plus leur fonction vous avez un
point en plus
il faut leur fonction aussi vous avez un
Mathilde une idée
de la Commission européenne et
Charles Michel
bon allez je vous attends quand même
deux points vous égalisez avec Mathilde
vous avez 1,5 points Gabriel vous avez
deux points
je suis désolé alors juste
la présidente de la Commission
européenne et Charles Michel et
président de l'Union européenne voilà
pour cette quatrième question 5e
question regardez ces images
est-ce que vous pouvez me donner le nom
de l'émission sur l'Europe que diffusait
TV 78 auparavant
là c'est connaissance de la chaîne
je le savais j'ai oublié
vous connaissez très bien votre
employeur
[Musique]
alors réponse ATIS l'Europe et nous non
Mathilde Europe vous avez un élément de
réponse on va vous donner un demi point
parce que c'est dans ma réponse alors la
réponse est bien c'était le 7 8 Europe
présenté par Nicolas Kerry Lovitz que je
salue aujourd'hui TV 78 diffuse
l'émission zone Europe produit par radio
sensation présenté par Corentin Alonso
voulait dire bonjour à Corentin
peut-être bonjour Corentin et qui est
disponible
merci Corentin d'avoir apporté un demi
point Gabriel Gontier et donc cette
émission vous pouvez la voir bien
évidemment sur notre antenne et sur
notre chaîne YouTube allez dernière
question écoutez bien cet extrait vous
pouvez marquer des points vous pourrez
pas rattraper Gabriel mais je pense que
vous pouvez marquer des points
automatique vous pouvez allez
la mobilité européenne une action
visible par les jeunes Yvelines c'est la
mission du Bureau d'information jeunesse
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce centre
départemental d'information auprès des
jeunes et labellisés Eurodesk il y a
quand même des fonds qui sont dédiés à
la mobilité des jeunes et qui sont pas
forcément toujours très connus de ces
jeunes
alors il y a un dispositif européen qui
est sous-entendu dans ce sujet est-ce
que vous pouvez me donner lequel
dispositif européen politique publique
européenne
très simple
mesure phare de l'Union européenne
on parle de mobilité de jeunes
pour la jeunesse
très bonne réponse de Mathilde Franco il
s'agit bien évidemment d'Erasmus un
dispositif
un dispositif européen qui permet à des
étudiants et bien de toute l'Union
européenne de pouvoir aller faire leurs
études dans un autre pays membre
européen et c'est t'aider et accompagné
voilà donc il semblerait que vous ayez
trois points et demi Mathilde je compte
pas Nicolas
Gabriel vous faites doubler juste à la
fin parce que ces deux points et demi
ouais c'est donc victoire de Mathilde de
Franco ce soir merci Nicolas dandry pour
pour ce quiz on en apprend toujours
davantage grâce au quiz du jeudi c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le temps devrait rester
dégagé sur l'ensemble du département au
niveau des températures il fera 9 degrés
à Houdan et Rambouillet et 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles dans
l'après-midi la pluie fera son
apparition dans les Yvelines
attendez-vous à quelques averses côté
température comptez environ 14 à 15
degrés en moyenne et pour les prévisions
météo de ce week-end comme d'habitude
maintenant c'est notre Mr météo
nationale Thomas Fletcher qui prend les
commandes il s'est intéressé à la
Journée mondiale de l'orgue dans ce
nouveau numéro alors quoi de beau
regardez
alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
ce dimanche c'est la journée mondiale de
l'orgue
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une église
accompagnée de Jean-Marc élève organiste
ici à Coignières dans les Yvelines bien
sûr alors quoi de beau ce weekend
[Musique]
ça c'est une note de musique ça c'est un
tuyau je peux taper ça donnera rien du
tout ça c'est les notes les plus basses
tremblement de terre
on dit que les claviers sont accouplés
ok alors pourquoi parce qu'en général
l'organisme il a qu'une demande en
général et tu peux faire en trois genre
tu mets le pied sur un truc ça fait les
trois
merci chef
[Rires]
[Musique]
et le voisinage il se plaint pas ah non
parce que ça ne fait pas de bruit du
vent bon bien sûr si on met à fond la
caisse le voisin seront enchantés
[Musique]
et au fur et à mesure
et on enlève
et maintenant
terminée il y a plus de vent qui
on peut jouer de la guitare
donc il faut abréger ah ouais la largeur
par rapport du sommier au clavier
[Musique]
facteur quand il accorde ça fait
c'est tout à coup on entend un son
unique il dit c'est bon et on passe à la
note d'après merci Jean-Marc et merci
aux amis de l'ordre de Coignières de
nous avoir laissé jouer ce bel
instrument
[Musique]
voilà maintenant que vous en saurez un
peu plus sur l'orgue c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]